what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so giving into superior Ironman
really into the conclusion of this story
I told you guys previously this is
pretty short superior Ironman is a is a
very short story but it's also really
cool because this is really just kind of
like place filter leading into secret
Wars but the idea for those of you guys
who have not seen the first video which
you'll find the Ironman playlist down in
the description but the whole idea
behind the first video was that this
basically served the purpose of giving
us this really dark and sarcastic and
really kind of sadistic version of Tony
Stark after the events of axis of course
axis being the event where it basically
saw the personalities of a lot of
Earth's superheroes being inverted
meaning good guys became bad guys bad
guys became good guys now we're the
spell was eventually reversed Tony Stark
shielded himself from the spell he's
basically a bad guy now and as it
unfolds is actually not gonna be one of
these things worse like well I mean he's
kind of a bad guy depending on how you
look at it he's actually gonna be a bad
guy and again the way this really starts
out is with the idea of him meeting up
with the federal government now remember
when it came to superior Iron Man in the
first video we had talked about how he
had basically launched extremis 3.0
which is to say the third iteration of
this extremist tech that could be used
to biologically alter people now he had
done this for the purpose of making
everybody in San Francisco beautiful and
then charging them a hundred dollars a
day in order to basically stay that way
but the idea is that he's shooting for
much bigger here and again that fits in
line with Tony Stark and we'll talk
about that here in a minute but of
course what he ends up doing is selling
something to the federal government
which is worth about two hundred million
dollars but of course he also tells the
tells the US military he has an offer
for China and for the for Russia as well
presumably for the same thing now we're
not told explicitly what it is that he's
selling but whatever it is that he sells
it's worth 200 million dollars now what
he sells is not relevant what is
relevant is the fact that he's got two
hundred million bucks and the questions
being asked what's he gonna do with it
now of course this question is being
asked by Pepper Potts as well as classic
Iron Man and that's the other half of
the equation because of the fact that
Tony Stark had basically become a
villain of sorts what we ended up
finding out is there was an instance
where by he fought a villain called
black llama and because of the fact that
the battle almost cost him his life on
the off chance that he ended up being
killed Tony Stark actually backed up his
own
mine with his memories experiences the
whole nine yards so that if you were to
die that backup could be used presumably
thrown into a cloned body or something
along those lines and he in turn would
be able to continue on his normal life
and so because of this this backed up
version this classic Iron Man is
basically his original stuff it's the
way he was before the events of axis
ended up taking place now of course what
this does is it makes things on a
strange here because what we'll actually
find out is that because they're
basically the same person that this
classic Iron Man is actually gonna have
some pretty nefarious motives what we
also end up learning is that with this
$200,000,000 the goal of Tony Stark is
to actually travel to one of the biggest
media Mongols in the world buy them out
and then use them for his own purposes
now with this instance it's all done for
the purpose of him basically forcing
these guys hands now this is a publicly
traded company and what that means is
that he's actually able to go through
and just take it over with a hostile
takeover by a massive amount of shares
but in order to basically force their
hand what he actually ends up doing is
leaking to the press the idea that he
wants to buy this news outlet now it
puts these guys in a rock and a hard
place and the reason why is because
while this guy is the CEO and while he
is basically the guy that helped to
build the company
he's beholding to the shareholders his
company is only as valuable as its stock
value and so if the stock price begins
to fall then suddenly his company will
become virtually worthless but because
of this Tony Stark uses that to his
advantage to basically say people are
gonna start pulling out if you don't
give them answers so either you can
accept my offer or you can turn down my
offer but my offer is gonna go through
one way or another now of course what we
end up finding out here is this company
is not going to sell out to Iron Man and
the reason why is because they already
have a buyer and that buyer is in the
form of Pepper Potts now in the last
video we had talked about how Pepper
Potts a massive amount of wealth that
she has at her disposal comes by way of
resilient resilient was basically this
company that was formed by Tony Stark in
which Pepper Potts was put in charge of
just because of the fact that with her
close proximity to Tony Stark to Ironman
as part of Stark Industries it
constantly made her a target for the
various villains that he was facing and
so the idea of Ironman was to basically
form this company called stark resilient
that would serve the purpose of creating
all these different products for making
people's lives better phone products and
different things like that and then in
turn Pepper Potts would be put in charge
to that company that way anybody
coming after Ironman would have no
reason to believe that she was attached
to his company and so because of that
she has this massive corporate wealth
behind her and of course she ends up
buying out this major media outlet
because she had really just kind of
guessed that's most likely what he was
going to do but what this also does is
its Brees classic Tony Stark and
superior Tony Stark face-to-face and so
what ends up happening is this suit of
course takes off it ends up battling
superior Iron Man for a little bit but
then almost immediately takes him
prisoner and what ends up happening here
is this suit of armor reveals its own
purpose this classic Iron Man or this
classic Tony Stark basically says that
superior Iron Man is a bad guy
the world is better off without him and
so what does classic Iron Man intends to
do against the wishes of Pepper Potts is
to actually wife the mind of superior
Iron Man and put his own line in its
place again basically achieving this
ulterior motive for its creation in the
first place albeit against the wishes of
superior Tony Stark and so once they
actually into the mindscape is really
kind of cool because what this does is
it gives us this perspective of how
superior Iron Man actually sees himself
I mean as we would expect with Tony
Stark he's all about himself when they
go into the mindscape of superior Iron
Man is exactly what we think it is it's
just super hot chicks parties all the
time everybody thinks she's the most
important person ever and people idolize
him that's really about it but what
classic Iron Man does not know is that
superior Iron Man's actually using his
armor using his endo sim tech to
actually infiltrate the classic Iron Man
suit now remember this would be like if
you faced off against a version of
yourself from ten years ago the version
of yourself and ten years ago does not
have all the experience that you gained
over the last 10 years and so because of
this the immediate goal is to seize
control of superior Iron Man and then in
turn just kind of move forward from
there now of course what this also ends
up doing is it leads to superior Iron
Man of course destroying this armor by
virtue of using his own jindo sim suit
the problem with this is it's like the
Terminator series in trying to destroy
Skynet Skynet was everywhere it's like
trying to stop the Internet the
Internet's all over the place because of
that this digital backup cannot be
destroyed through conventional means
which is to say it's not housed in a
suit instead as long as this suits
destroyed another one will come for
superior Iron Man it'll always work that
way because it's a digital backup and so
the idea
of superior Ironman of Tony Stark is to
basically figure out where this AI is
being stored and then destroy its
location deleting the artificial
intelligence the problem with this is
that trying to locate Tony Stark becomes
infinitely more difficult and the reason
for this is because of the fact that he
actually takes refuge back in San
Francisco and literally just starts this
massive party now this is important
because if this were superior Iron Man
going for somebody else it would just be
collateral damage and he wouldn't care
that's how his personality is now that's
how it's been inverted
but with this classic Iron Man
collateral damage it's not something to
consider it's better to simply not
attack and to attack where innocence or
present what does does is it allows a
superior Iron Man the chance to
basically begin going through all these
documents going through these databases
chasing down information as best he can
until he manages to come across where it
is that this digital backup is being
stored at now of course with him making
this declaration that he knows what's
going on that he knows where everybody
is taunting this classic version of
himself to come after him what it does
is it leads to the endo sim armor facing
off against all the previous suits of
Iron Man and that's cool because what
this does is just designed to highlight
just how far Tony Stark has come in the
development of his Iron Man suits now
the idea here is that with the endo
simcha it was designed to be superior
that's how Iron Man operates and it just
makes logical sense each suit is
supposed to be better than the last and
so because of this the idea of Iron Man
is to basically use the Indus Mr Murr to
take out every single one of these suits
which efore the most part successfully
does but not without having to bring out
the big guns because of the fact that
he's facing off against suits like the
Hulkbuster armor dealth suits different
things like that what he ends up doing
is actually utilizing the endo sim armor
to its fullest capacity and that was the
purpose of it right like the purpose of
the endo seminar more was to be this
all-encompassing suit
it was literally a Swiss Army knife it
could be anything for any given
situation and so because of that he
literally just cuts a swath through
every single one of these armors that he
has it's no real contest he's able to
take every single one of these guys out
until Pepper Potts emerges in her own
Iron Man suit now this gives Tony Stark
pause to stop and the reason for this is
because on the surface it actually looks
like he still cares about Pepper Potts
basically says look okay I'm not going
to attack you now of course where he
refuses to stay
down pepper ends up using a sonic device
on a suit now the reason why this seems
to work is because the endo sim armor is
designed and modeled after the symbiote
suit which is to say venom carnage with
a venom and carnage symbionts sound is
one of the biggest weaknesses they have
as well as fire I do not believe fire is
a weakness for carnage but I believe it
is for honor I know it is for venom but
regardless because it's based on
symbiote tech it just made logical sense
with pepper potts knowing about the
history of iron man being well aware
about all the villains that exists out
there to basically use whatever ability
she can to her own advantage to take out
the suit now of course this knocks Tony
Stark out brings him back to stark
resilient that kind of a thing but
because of the fact that he had figured
out where the database for these Iron
Man suits are out where this digital
backup is located what he did is
actually instill a virus inside stark
resilient and what this does is it
literally sources out and it goes
through every single threat of code it
goes through every database every hard
drive the whole nine yards and it seeks
out every little bit of this digital
backup of himself that exists out there
and deletes them all and so because of
this once it's done and once it's pulled
off he literally just says and were
finished here of course he donned a
superior Iron Man suit and walks away
but not before throwing a cherry on top
what he basically does is wear Pepper
Potts believes he can still be redeemed
what he says is no I tricked you I led
you to believe that you could defeat me
when Pepper Potts makes the case of
saying hey I - I stripped you of your
armor was before I could strip you again
he basically says look do you really
believe that I would have made a suit
that had a weakness to loud noises all I
would have to do is fly through a
construction site and suddenly I lose
everything suddenly the suit comes
crashing down or something along those
lines and so what he basically reveals
here is that Pepper Potts is not someone
he cares about Pepper Potts is a means
to an end now this is huge because
historically speaking when it came to
pepper while there was some sort of a
you know strained romantic relationship
between the two of them where were
always those instances where Tony Stark
basically indicated he wanted to get
with pepper they never really did and so
because of that pepper feels a huge
betrayal because despite all that they
were still extremely close friends
pepper was like the one person in the
world that Ironman trusts and she
trusted him more than anybody else and
so because that for him to basically say
no
yura means to an end you're just a way
for me to basically achieve my goal it
destroys everything
she believes about herself it destroys
the idea that she felt like she was
actually a friend to him so what this
does is it basically picks up of course
with Tony Stark at Stark headquarters
and then it segues itself into Secret
Wars now the problem with this is the
continuity of this story we could argue
this story resides just before the
incursions we could argue this story
resides before the incursions even
started happening we don't know the
exact placement of this or at least I
haven't been able to find it I mean
there's reading orders and all the
reading order simply say this is the
story before Secret Wars because the
last page says on to Secret Wars 2015
let's go check it out but in terms of
the events of the story all indications
seem to be that in Secret Wars issue
number 0 where Captain America and Iron
Man fought for the last time did that
version of Iron Man that version of Tony
Stark is superior Iron Man that he's
still basically the bad guy but again
it's just kind of the things that he
says that leads us to believe that more
so than a declaration of I am superior
Iron Man and I'm funning against Captain
America now but without being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you guys are new here
two comments explain it make sure you
guys to the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]